Well.
So taking the red pill on,
on freewill makes you much more
forgiving of a lot of this stuff.
Yeah. Cause you see just
everyone is an open system. Uh,
no one authored themselves, right.
One created the themselves. No one,
no one can directly regulate the effect
that of every influence that they had or
didn't have. You know, it's like you,
you are the totality of
what brought you here.
I mean the universe has sort of just push
you to this point in time and the only
thing you've got is your brain
and it states and that is,
that is based on your genes and the
totality of environmental influences. You,
your,
you had a system have,
have had working on you
up until this moment.
And so the next words that come out of
your mouth are part of that process.
Now, the peep. Some people find
this to be, uh, uh, you know,
frankly demoralizing picture or
they think, well, okay, well I'm,
you're telling me, telling me I'm just a
robot. But you're a robot that is open,
continuously open to influence,
to influence of either internally
based on its own processes.
I mean there's like there's top
down control of, of, you know,
you're the executive function
in the brain to your, you know,
your emotional life say,
and you're continually open
to the influences of culture,
right?
You know,
the cultures as operating system that
you're interacting with in each moment and
whatever's getting in can change you
in radical ways very quickly. I mean,
there's no telling how much you can
change on the basis of one new idea coming
your way right now.
I would argue that the process of change,
I mean if I say something that changes
your view on anything that's not evidence
of freewill, that is evidence of just
yet more causality. I mean, you don't,
you don't pick the changes
that come your way. If I,
if I get you to see something that
you didn't see a moment before,
you're not responsible for the fact that
you didn't see it a moment before and
you're not responsible for
the fact that you now see it.
It's just like the dominoes just
kept falling. Right. Right. Um,
but it does give you this a
far more patient sense of,
um, one, just it just, you know,
all the causes and conditions
that, that have created, the, this,
this odious behavior. You're,
you're, you're now disposed
to react to in the world,
right? Like, like you can,
everything on some level is,
is more of a force of nature than it
is something that you need to take
personally. It's like if there's
a hurricane blowing outside,
we don't respond to it the same
way we would respond to, you know,
al Qaeda and dropping a bomb on
us. Right? It could, it might,
it might create the same amount
of damage, but in, in the,
in the latter case where
we have an identifiable, an
identifiable agent, right?
We feel like,
okay,
now we're in the presence of human
evil and we have to go kill these
motherfuckers right now we
may have to kill them, right?
Because that may be the only way of, of,
of putting out this, this, you know, uh,
s stopping the damage there.
They're committed to causing, but,
and we would kill hurricanes if we could
kill them, right? I mean, we would,
you know,
we would nullify them,
but the feeling we have in
both cases is very different.
The feeling you have attributing ultimate
authorship to a person's behavior is
super, uh, narrow, uh,
psychologically and ethically. And it's,
you know, the feeling of vengeance, right?
Like, like you don't, you, you don't,
you have this feeling of vengeance is so
natural to get triggered in response to
a person.
It's not natural and response to a
wild animal who may have done something
terrible. Right? I mean,
like, you would like, I mean,
there've been examples of this where
people have taken vengeance on animals and
it just looks like a kind
of moral dysfunction on the
part of the people who did
it. I mean, there's a famous
picture of a, an elephant.
They got hung from a railroad crane, I
think back in the 20s right? So like,
if this is a circus, elephant
escaped and it ran, you know,
you just rampage through the streets
and trampled, let you know a few people.
And the, and the people in the, in
the town, I don't know where this was,
it was a Baltimore or someplace.
We're so outraged that they've decided
to lynch the elephant, right? Like,
and yet that's,
there's something uncanny about that
sort of misappropriation of agency to an
elephant. But what, what is it,
what is a mistreated circus elephant
going to do when he gets out and is
terrified and he's trying
to get away from people?
It's going to trample a few people.
So we have a very different set of
books we keep ethically for humans.
And
some of it's understandable,
some of it's inevitable,
but a lot of it gives us moral
illusions that we don't need to have.
And it gives a, it gives us a kind of, uh,
just an inability to take stock of all
the variables that are actually guiding
human behavior and react to them and
mitigate them and disincentivize them
intelligently. I mean,
punishment makes sense.
Not because people really,
really deserve at bottom,
whatever their punishments are,
it doesn't make sense in a,
in a retro retributive paradigm,
it makes sense if,
if it's the,
the best tool to discourage
dangerous behavior.
Uh, and it works, right? So
it's like, you know, if you're,
if you're going to punish people
for things they can't control,
well that's stupid,
right? Because it's you,
as much as you punish them
that you're not gonna,
you're not gonna moderate the behavior.
So you have to punish people for things
that are actually under voluntary
control.
And it only,
it only makes sense if it's
the only tool to do the job.
And if the moment you had,
I mean to this is,
I may have brought this up last
time we spoke about free will,
but this is really,
they sort of reductio ad absurdum of,
of where most people are on this topic.
The moment we really understand
human evil at the level of the brain,
the moment we understand
psychopathy say, which is, I mean,
maybe that's not the totality of evil,
but that's certainly
center of the Bullseye.
Once we understand psychopathy is a
neurological condition that's governed by
genes and environment and we can,
we can actually intrude at the
level of the brain to mitigate it.
So like psychopathy becomes a
disease, right? It becomes a,
a an injuries syndrome, right? That
we can fix. And let's say it's,
let's say it's a very simple
fix. I'll say it's a pill, right?
Let's say it's just a neurotransmitter
imbalance in the presence of that
breakthrough,
we will feel very differently
about that species of human evil.
We will not judge it in
the same way will it?
Because what will happen is you'll give
people the pill and they'll say, fuck,
I can't believe I was that
dangerous asshole. Like,
like the thank you for like,
like I,
I'm as horrified by who I was
before you cured me as you were.
Right?
And so it'll be so,
so suck psychopathy and the presence of
a cure for it would look much more like
diabetes than it looks like evil in the
present case and people aren't imagining
what it would like.
What would it be like to be there?
What it would be like to actually
fully understand the under underlying
neurophysiology here and actually
have something. I mean it's,
there's no guarantee we'll be able to,
to, uh, deal with it in a simple way,
but it's certainly possible.
Um, and I mean the,
the classic example is just, you know,
like the Charles Whitman example where,
you know, you have a brain tumor
that's causing this aberrant behavior.
In that case, everyone, everyone
sees, okay, this is not evil.
This is a brain tumor.
That's the tower shooter game back in 64.
I think. Um, and so,
but in the same way that a brain,
tuber tumors exculpatory there,
I think a full understanding of the,
the underlying neurology
would be exculpatory again.
It doesn't mean you in the meantime,
you know, before we get there,
we have obviously we have to lock up
dangerous people if there's no way to,
to help them.
But the more we see the causes,
the more we view,
we view this in terms
of just sheer bad luck,
right? Like, like there are,
there are people who when they're
adults are quintessentially evil,
who we've, who and they provoke the
greatest feeling of vengeance from us.
But if you just walk back there timeline,
you recognize it at a certain,
they were four years old at one point,
right?
They were the four year old who was
destined to become this terrible person.
It's an unlucky four year old,
you know? And so at what point,
where's the bright line that says,
okay,
here's the point where it's appropriate.
Just hate this person and
feel no compassion. And on
the other side of this line,
you should just feel compassion
because this person's unlucky.
There is no such line and a complete
understanding of this lifeline in,
in scientific terms would obliterate
any line you think you have.
Right? It would just be this
cascade of causation. And you know,
adding randomness to the picture
doesn't help. Right? It's just,
it's the randomness is just,
you know,
somebody is in your brain rolling dice
and influencing your behavior that way.
Well that's, that doesn't give you the,
the freewill people think they have.
So there isn't,
there's a,
ironically there is what seems
on some level deflationary
of the, of the, the,
the,
the Gravitas of the human spirit for
people opens the door to at least in my
view,
a far more ethical and tolerant and
patient and understanding view of,
of, you know, human failings and,
and human frailty and, and just,
and then at that point you can just have
a conversation about what's pragmatic,
what works, what helps
people change. Like in this,
this person over here who's
doing terrible things,
is there something we can do to make him
a better person? Well, if there is less,
do that without all the judgment.
Wouldn't it be amazing if that's how
we treated these public shaming events?
Like wouldn't, wouldn't it be amazing if
we gave someone an opportunity to say,
this is, this is what I did, this
is how awful I feel about this.
I would never do that again. I'm a
different person. That was 20 years ago,
whatever it was and, and have
everybody join in. Hey, um,
anyone could be you. Thank you for
being honest about who you are now.
Thank you for evolving.
Thank you for expressing yourself in a
way that maybe other people who have also
committed,
really,
I'm just unsavory or just
unfortunate things in the past.
Unfortunate acts in the past,
they can feel relieved by the fact that
you've grown and evolved to become a
better person. Yeah. And that you're a,
you're a different thing now and you are
the product of all of your experiences.
You're not,
you're not this one thing.
You're not stuck in who you
were when you were 16 years old.
If you were Marky mark and you hit that
guy with a stick, whatever, you know,
whatever he did, you didn't, you're
not stuck in that spot forever.
These don't Mar,
it's not a scarlet letter.
It's not a mark on your forehead
that you keep for life. Yeah. I mean,
the thing about the Liam Neeson incident,
which I find so interesting is
that there's a case where, I mean,
what he's revealing about himself is,
is pretty amazing, right? It's like,
it's like he just decided, okay, we,
we need a truth and Reconciliation
Commission for who I used to be. Right.
You know? And, uh,
just volunteered this and
for me like, like, you know,
I don't actually understand
that state of mind.
I mean there are many ab or in
states of mind that I can understand.
I certainly understand what it's like to,
to want to harm somebody and to,
you know, to feel vengeance and all that.
But the instrumental violence piece,
I don't understand. I've
never felt like, okay,
this type of person wronged
me or someone close to me.
So any time any person of that
type we'll do right like that.
But that is such a problem. The
world over in human history. Yes.
That it is,
it is just fascinating
ethically for someone of his
stature to reveal that about
himself. And he put it in terms of,
of of honor. I mean it was like a,
it was an honor.
I mean this is one,
this is w w what is so dysfunctional
about honor culture, right? This is what,
this is what we see more in the south
than anywhere else in the country.
And this is what you see
basically everywhere you go
in the Middle East is this,
and this is what Islam inculcates to
a degree that's fairly unmatched in,
in its community.
This notion of honor is,
does link up with this tendency to find
satisfaction in instrumental violence.
Like when you, when you try to
run that software on my brain,
that just looks like madness,
right?
The idea that any other person will do
right of a certain type that's just,
you know, I don't read, that
resonates not at all. Right? And so,
um,
it's just damn interesting and the fact
that the lesson being taken from this
seems to be,
this is,
this should be the end of your career
for having talked about this in the way.
And again,
I apologize if there's some part of the
story that I've gotten wrong or I'm not
missing or missing,
but it seemed to me that he was
always counting this in the,
the horror and amazement
appropriate to the disclosure.
Like he can't believe he was inhabiting
this date of loss of consciousness. And,
you know, it's just an amazing thing
to reveal about yourself. Uh, so, yeah.
And I'm sure he regrets every
second of it. Yeah. And that's,
that's the wrong fucking
punchline, right? You know,
the thing that should happen is
someone with a lot to lose
should be able to say, you know,
how ugly a human mind can be. This
is an experience I had, right?
This is who I was,
and you know,
how much I have to live for
and how much I have to lose.
We have to talk about this kind of mania.
They can get Hamid on a human brain.
Right? Right. And we see this eight,
every time you open the paper, you see
someone in the grip of this kind of thing.
Right. Even happened to me. Right. I think
it's an amazing conversation to start,
and the fact that the result
is just, you know, and,
and an auto de fe, uh, is,
is a, is the problem. We're,
we're trying to fight our way through it.